a company out of Oklahoma is producing
for $1000 bulletproof blankets for kids
to use in schools because of this is the
same amount of school shootings of
course we had another one yesterday it
just never stopped there was a one the
week before we've got some images of the
blankets so yeah a thousand bucks it can
protect against 90% of the weapons that
have been used in school shootings in
the United States there were 13 school
shootings in the US the first six weeks
of 2014 we're now four months past that
so I guess first is this just inevitable
that every kid is going to be going to
school with a bulletproof blanket I
don't even have words for how appalling
the idea that we now have two Kevlar our
kids blankets in schools because god
forbid we do any tiny tiny thing about
guns in this country and said no we all
have to walk around with bulletproof
vests that's the answer I'm I can't even
I mean I definitely think they're a good
idea you know I mean they they're
attempting to solve there's something to
put out the smoke rather than put out
the fire right now for lack of a better
expression but because it doesn't look
like gun reform is happening anytime
soon in this country and people were
actually dying you know I mean there was
just another shooting that occurred you
know yesterday I think that to have
those in schools would be a positive
thing and the and the bulletproof doors
that they've been experimenting isn't it
all a little bit of sort of fake
protection because the idea that the kid
would be you know when this would happen
I assume they don't keep them on them
all the time or probably even under
their desks that you know uni and by the
time you were able to get it out of the
closet or something the bad stuff is
already happen so a lot of this is just
sort of just I don't know is it is it
fakery for the parents mind is it
telling kids oh by the way you could get
shot at any moment so do keep this handy
ya know so that's the part that I think
the most interesting do you think that
we that the real bad part is is the
conditioning that all these kids are
gonna grow up thinking that this is just
really part of the way life is
even though I guess it is at some level
but I think that you have to adapt to
the times like I went to high school or
I should say elementary school in
Manhattan
and we I remember growing up we had
drills where we would have to get under
the desks in case there was a like a
nuclear attack or something like that I
remember there was you had to get under
the desks and brace yourself for some
kind of like attack or something like
that yeah yeah and this was like in New
York and obviously I don't think that
that applies today but today we have
this very real and present you know
danger of school shootings inside
something I read online this week that I
thought was interesting was that one of
the great semantic sort of you know
twists of recent years is that we keep
calling these shootings and nobody ever
calls them murderers and that if we
called them murderers maybe we would
take them more seriously but shootings
just sort of seems more innocuous and
that and that's allowed us to kind of
process this in a daily basis that it's
constantly happening and we aren't more
appalled by them yeah is that the other
scary part here is that so when I saw
the shooting yesterday I don't even
remember where it was where was it
because this happens constantly right it
was in Oregon and I guess the shooter
and one other student at North Hollywood
a couple days ago right and then what
was the one last week last week was in
Santa Barbara right or was that a week
and half ago but I think it's happening
and this goes to the conditioning part
is when I see on Twitter there's a
shooting now it doesn't even faze me for
a split second or you know you mean I'm
like oh another one like and that to me
is the scary part so are we just
becoming someone oh yeah I mean are we
just becoming more and more okay with
this so I so this is something these
blankets even if it's not real
protection your flanks are completely
exposed on those things you know like
you need a dome at least or something
like a big turtle shell I mean if they
save one life you know it's a great
initiative yeah so if we can't change
the gun laws which it seems like we
can't seem to do since we couldn't get
anything passed after Newtown and Sandy
Hook if we can't do that then what what
should we be tackling should be tacking
mental health more because it seems to
me there's a lot there's a lot to do
with mental health and prescription drug
one said yesterday though with their
withers mentally hella mentally ill
people all over the world and there are
violent video game
all over the world and there are
frustrated single guys all over the
world this is the country where all
those people get guns yeah yes and if
video games cause violence as I say
every time I'd be an Italian plumber
eating mushrooms jumping on Turtles and
I am but that is nothing to do with the
video game